[Applaudissements]
le 21e siècle on peut être plutôt le 22e
les quatre coins du monde de gigantesque
fusées parte à la conquête des étoiles à
leur bord des hommes des ingénieurs des
chercheurs avides de connaissances
d'aventure et l'espace
ils cherchent des réponses qui n'a
jamais rêvé de voir ça navette
s'enfoncer au cœur de l'espace profond
qui n'a jamais rêvé de ses galaxies
lointaines peuplées de légende ou de
faire une rencontre du troisième type
par exemple au détour d'une lune de la
planète Saturne
qui n'a jamais souhaité voir le soleil
guider sa navette au cœur de l'espace
profond vers l'infini et l'espoir d'y
trouver un monde meilleur
certains d'entre vous ont peut-être
reconnu ce qui m'a inspiré cette
introduction il s'agit d'une de
l'introduction à peine détournée d'une
série télévisée une série d'animations
qui a été diffusée pour la première fois
en France dans les années 80 il s'agit
des Mystérieuses Cités d'Or qui
relataient la découverte et
l'exploration de l'Amérique au pays des
grandes des hauts au moment des grandes
découvertes justement en suivant les
aventures de trois jeunes enfants d'une
douzaine d'années Esteban Zia et Tao et
je me souviens qu'à cette époque là
j'avais adoré cette série
et c'est sans doute cette série qui m'a
donné le goût des explorations et des
découvertes
aujourd'hui
déjà à cette époque je m'appelle Fabrice
berthil et je satisfais ma soif de
curiosité de connaissances et ma
curiosité en étant chercheur au CNRS à
l'Institut pluridisciplinaire
uber-curien à Strasbourg
mes études ont pour but de tenter de
mieux comprendre comment certains
animaux réussissent à survivre
apparemment sans problème à des
conditions environnementales difficiles
conditions face auxquelles nous humains
développerions des maladies
par exemple les animaux hibernants sont
capables tous les ans de rester pendant
plus de la moitié de l'année
complètement inactif et sans manger et
ceci sans problème et dans ce contexte
je m'intéresse plus particulièrement à
la biologie des ours qui peuplent les
forêts suédoises
mais aujourd'hui je vais vous embarquer
dans un voyage vers l'espace profond
vous avez bien compris je ne sais pas si
ici certains parmi vous même si je me
suis un petit peu emballé au départ en
imaginant un monde où la conquête de
l'espace serait devenue chose banale je
ne sais pas si parmi vous il y en a qui
serait prêt à s'embarquer aujourd'hui
pour un voyage vers Mars
et vous bousculez pas
parce qu'il y a quelques petits points
avant de partir qu'il nous faudrait
régler quelques clips quelques petits
points qui ne sont pas forcément anodins
je vous propose d'éliminer tout de suite
la question du pourquoi pourquoi partir
à côté du fait que des sommes colossales
sont en jeu et en mettant de côté
malheureusement
la pollution spatiale dont on entend de
plus en plus parler en mettant également
de côté la question du tourisme spatial
et bien l'absence de gravité qu'on
trouve dans l'espace permet tout
simplement aux scientifiques de faire
des découvertes qui sont impossibles sur
terre et les technologies qui sont
développées dédiées spécifiquement à
l'exploration spatiale et le bien elle
trouve des applications concrètes ici
sur Terre par exemple l'observation du
climat mais également le développement
de technologie précise pour la chirurgie
du cerveau
pour réussir à voyager dans l'espace
on a besoin de répondre à la question du
comment
faire voyager des personnes dans
l'espace ça nécessite de pouvoir
s'arracher
à l'attraction terrestre à la gravité
terrestre et ça nécessite évidemment
également de pouvoir assurer la santé de
nos voyageurs la santé de nos
astronautes pendant des mois voire
pendant des années santé qui est menacé
évidemment par un envie un environnement
spatial qui reste somme toute très
hostile puisque confinés loin de la
Terre soumis à des rayonnements
cosmiques et sans pesanteur
et bien
pouvoir plonger les voyageurs les
astronautes dans un état de
l'hibernation ou un état proche de
l'hibernation comme ce que réalise cette
écureuil terrestre à certaines périodes
de l'année pourraient nous aider à
favoriser ces deux éléments en effet ça
pourrait nous aider parce que de cette
manière on pourrait emporter moins de
vivre moins d'oxygène on produirait
moins de déchets et donc ce gain de
poids nous permettrait de nous arracher
beaucoup plus facilement à l'attraction
terrestre
l'état hibernant pourrait également
aider
à lutter contre les effets délétères de
l'environnement spatial les effets
délétères qui rassemblent par exemple la
fonte des muscles la fragilisation des
eaux qu'on appelle aussi les ostéoporose
et puis également toutes les toutes les
attaques toutes les agressions qui sont
dues aux radiations cosmiques par
exemple sur l'ADN et puis hiberner
pendant ce voyage très long ça
permettrait aussi de lutter facilement
contre l'ennui ou contre le mal de
l'espace qui est dû au confinement ou
qui est dû tout simplement à
l'éloignement vis-à-vis de la terre
mais qu'est-ce que l'hibernation
hibernation c'est une stratégie que la
nature a mis en place chez certains
animaux pour leur permettre justement de
survivre à des conditions difficiles
conditions difficiles par exemple
l'hiver des périodes très des
températures très froides et une absence
de nourriture
hibernation ça correspond à un état
léthargique dans lequel l'animal va
entrer et pendant lequel il va réduire
évidemment
sa prise alimentaire mais également son
activité physique et puis il s'agit
d'économiser de l'énergie donc
globalement
le métabolisme de nos animaux hibernants
il va s'effondrer
de même que le rythme cardiaque de même
que la fréquence respiratoire et puis
enfin la température corporelle des
animaux en général va chuter
drastiquement
vous reconnaissez sans doute un certain
nombre de ces animaux tous ces animaux
sont des animaux hibernants vous voyez
qu'il y a beaucoup de mammifères vous
reconnaissez en haut à gauche la
marmotte et puis si on descend ensuite
vous avez des lois des
déliros si on se déplace un peu sur la
droite la moufette des chauves-souris on
rencontre aussi de l'hibernation chez
certains reptiles vous avez des tortues
ici on rencontre de l'hibernation chez
certains batraciens et puis il y en a
une espèce d'oiseaux également qui
hibernent avec cet engoulement de
notable et alors à votre avis est-ce que
l'homme est-ce que l'homme peut être
plongé dans un état d'hibernation
et bien je vais vous donner tout de
suite
quelques éléments de réponse tout
d'abord en faveur de la possibilité
éventuelle de plonger un homme en
hibernation à gauche vous avez une
molécule vous avez je vous ai mis une
molécule ici parce que tous les
organismes quels qu'ils soient sont
globalement équipés de manière similaire
du point de vue moléculaire et donc
l'homme
théoriquement il est il a tout ce qu'il
faut il est équipé correctement pour
pouvoir hiberner notre difficulté ici
elle résidence faite dans notre capacité
à identifier tous les acteurs
moléculaires clés de l'hibernation et à
comprendre comment les contrôler pour
reproduire les régulations moléculaires
de l'hibernation
deuxième image des primates lémuriens de
Madagascar vous savez que nous sommes
des primates et bien ce primate il y a
quelques années on a découvert que
lorsqu'il disparaissait à certaines
périodes de l'année mais en fait c'était
pour aller hiberner donc même un primate
est capable d'exprimer le comportement
d'hibernation l'image suivante un homme
donnéandertal avec qui notre parenté ne
fait pas de doute quand on voit cette
image et bien récemment l'analyse de
certains de leurs eaux a révélé une
structure qui peut faire penser à des
périodes de diminuation ralentissement
de la croissance qui pourrait
correspondre
à des périodes d'hibernation
évidemment ça on n'en sera jamais sûr et
puis dernière image peut-être la plus
encourageante on est capable de
déclencher chez un animal
cette fameuse torpeur dont je parlais
tout à l'heure par exemple en haut on
est capable de déclencher une torpeur
chez cette souris en la plaçant dans un
environnement froid pour elle donc 22
degrés Celsius et puis on la priant un
petit peu de nourriture
pour le rat qui est en dessous on arrive
à le plonger dans cette situation de
torpeur en stimulant certains de ces
neurones qu'on appelle les neurones culs
et il n'est pas du tout interdit que
l'homme puisse posséder aussi ces fameux
neuronics
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est que au
réveil absolument aucune séquelle n'a
été détectée chez ces animaux
et pour autant il nous reste encore
beaucoup de travail évidemment
puisqu'on estime que prolonger cet état
de torpeur chez ces animaux au-delà
d'une dizaine de jours serait risqué
pour l'intégrité de certains de leurs
organes
qu'en est-il de l'homme maintenant dans
nos hôpitaux on pratique déjà ce qu'on
appelle l'hypothermie pardon
thérapeutique
l'hypothermittérapeutique ça consiste à
diminuer la température corporelle des
patients généralement des patients en
stade critique des patients en arrêt
cardiaque et en diminuant leur
température corporelle jusqu'à atteindre
environ 33 ou 34 degrés et bien en
ralentit ainsi leur métabolisme et on
gagne du temps pour pouvoir mieux les
traiter
et si on sait que cette situation elle
est bien supportée par les patients
pendant quelques heures jusqu'à dans
certains cas quelques jours
en dessous l'image c'est pour vous dire
que cette hypothermie thérapeutique elle
a également été testée chez des
organismes en bonne santé
mais pour des durées qui sont toujours
inférieur à 90 minutes donc là encore
pour l'homme il y a encore beaucoup de
travail avant de pouvoir atteindre la
possibilité ici de les faire
véritablement hiberner
l'étude de l'hibernation de l'ours
pourrait par contre nous aider
potentiellement
y parvenir pourquoi parce que cet animal
c'est un petit peu le champion de
l'hibernation par exemple en termes de
préservation de ces muscles c'est lui
qui parmi tous les animaux hibernants
préservent le mieux sa musculature et
puis par rapport aux petits animaux
hibernants qui vont mesurer quelques
grammes à quelques centaines de grammes
et celui-ci il a une physiologie et une
masse qui ressemble beaucoup plus à
celle de l'homme
et puis il y a encore un élément
extrêmement important ici je vous ai dit
que pendant l'hibernation il y avait une
chute de la température corporelle et
bien la chute de la température
corporelle de l'ours que lorsqu'il
hiberne n'est que de quelques degrés et
elle chute à 33 34 degrés Celsius donc
si il est difficile de concevoir placer
un humain à deux degrés de température
corporelle comme les petits rongeurs
hibernants il est en revanche beaucoup
plus facile peut-être de pouvoir penser
le placer à 33 ou 34 degrés Celsius pour
reproduire certains mécanismes de
l'hibernation 33 ou 35 degré Celsius
c'est ce que je vous ai dit qui était
utilisé en hypothermie thérapeutique
dans nos hôpitaux à l'heure actuelle
on a évoqué le comment maintenant on va
parler un petit peu après la théorie de
la pratique comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait
déclencher cette torpeur et la maintenir
donc on pourrait imaginer tout d'abord
après avant le grand voyage une période
de préconditionnement dans lequel comme
aujourd'hui les voyageurs les
astronautes s'entraîneraient
physiquement pour être en excellente
santé mais sans forcément
exclure la possibilité d'un certain
niveau d'engraissement pour que les
astronautes partent avec des calories
supplémentaires qui pourraient être
utilisées au cours de leur hibernation
spatiale et puis tout doucement on
pourrait les placer dans une dans une
ambiance froide dans une ambiance
fraîche froide on pourrait réduire
progressivement leur niveau d'activité
physique ensuite et puis on pourrait
restreindre leur alimentation on
pourrait également s'aider de solutions
pharmacologiques pour réduire
progressivement leur constante
physiologique donc finalement reproduire
tout ce qui se passe chez un animal
hibernant dans sa période de
préhibernation justement
et puis une fois la torpeur atteinte
bien il faudrait pouvoir assurer tout de
même un suivi et un maintien des
organismes en imaginant par exemple une
nutrition assistée par des perfusions
des perfusions de nutriments de
vitamines des perfusions de molécules
qui iraient spécifiquement protégés tel
ou tel organe nos travaux chez l'ours
par exemple on montrait que chez cet
animal en hiver lorsqu'ils hiberne il y
a des molécules qu'on aimerait bien
identifier qui circulent dans son sang
uniquement
pendant l'hibernation et qui sont
capables de protéger les muscles
on pourrait également toujours pour les
muscles par exemple les stimuler
électriquement pour les faire travailler
et encore une fois réussir à maintenir
leur masse
et leur force on pourrait tenter de
manipuler le microbiote intestinal de
nos voyageurs le microbiote intestinal
c'est la flore intestinale donc la
composition en micro-organismes qu'on
trouve dans l'intestin parce qu'il a été
montré chez les petits écureuils
hibernants qui entre l'hiver et l'été
entre l'état actif et l'hibernation ce
microbiote il est complètement remodelé
et les microorganismes qui sont
favorisés pendant l'hibernation et bien
ils sont capables de recycler au profit
de l'organisme entier l'azote et l'azote
c'est un élément essentiel pour
synthétiser les protéines synthétiser
les protéines ça veut dire
essentiellement fabriquer du muscle
et puis ça serait bien de pouvoir
monitorer suivre tout ça de manière
constante et de pouvoir ajuster toutes
ces constantes
sans cesse par exemple sous le contrôle
d'une intelligence artificielle
il nous reste maintenant une question à
laquelle on n'a pas répondu quand
quand est-ce qu'on va réussir est-ce
qu'on va réussir à faire hiberner des
hommes pour partir dans l'espace ou pour
autre chose en les plaçant dans des
capsules comme celle-ci qui étaient déjà
imaginées dans les années 60 par le
cinéma dans un film qui ici s'appelait
lost in space en 1965
quand pourra-t-on faire hiberner des
humains je dirais lorsqu'on saura
induire chez l'homme une torpeur
véritablement lorsqu'on sera la
maintenir sur de longues duré et surtout
lorsqu'on sera la reversé sans qu'il n'y
ait aucune séquelle aujourd'hui il reste
beaucoup de limites et on est encore
dans le domaine de la science-fiction
les limites ce sont les limites que peut
supporter le cerveau dans une situation
torpeur par exemple dans quel état va se
retrouver la mémoire au réveil est-ce
que nos voyageurs et nos astronautes
seront directement opérationnels pour
l'instant n'en est pas sûr est-ce que
nos solutions toutes celles qu'on va
suggérer susciter vont effectivement
réussir à protéger les organismes contre
les radiations on ne sait pas exactement
est-ce que tous les organes on va
réussir à les protéger de la même
manière on ne sait pas
et même si tout ça reste encore du
domaine de la science-fiction il y a
beaucoup de scientifiques et presque
toutes les agences spatiales qui
aujourd'hui s'intéressent à cette
solution pour voyager plus loin plus
profondément et plus longtemps dans
l'espace
et si on y arrive pas vous me direz
pas mais est-ce que ça serait si grave
finalement
puisque
tous les progrès qui vont être faits
toutes les avancées qui vont être
produites alors qu'on tente d'y arriver
et vont dire elles vont bénéficier
directement
à l'homme à sa technologie puis aussi à
sa santé
on va peut-être grâce à toutes ces
études trouver des solutions innovantes
pour aider encore plus à certaines à
lutter contre certaines pathologies la
fonte musculaire encore une fois la
fragilisation des eaux avec
l'ostéoporose donc chez les personnes
sédentaires les personnes obèses les
personnes âgées on pourrait peut-être
aussi comme ça mettre en dormance des
tumeurs pour gagner du temps ralentir
leur dynamique de croissance on pourrait
peut-être aussi comme ça apprendre à
conserver des organes à transplanter
pendant plus longtemps
et faire et augmenter la durée de vie
des greffons on pourrait peut-être aussi
réussir à lutter un petit peu mieux
contre les rayonnements contre les
radiations et aider ainsi des personnes
qui sont un petit peu plus exposées que
les autres comme celles qui sont la
plupart du temps dans des trajets longs
courriers par exemple ou des personnes
qui travaillent dans des centrales
nucléaires
et ben je vous propose qu'on fasse ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]